Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how a robot doggy
can help us explore dangerous areas without
putting humans at risk.
Well, not this one, mind you, because this
is not performing too well.
Why is that?
Well, this is a proprioceptive robot.
This means that the robot is essentially blind.
Yes.
Really.
It only senses its own internal state and
that’s it.
For instance, it knows about its orientation
and twist of the base unit, a little joint
information, like positions and velocities,
and that’s about it.
It is still remarkable that it can navigate
at all.
However, this often means that the robot has
to feel out the terrain before being able
to navigate on it.
Why would we do that?
Well, if we have difficult seeing conditions,
for instance, dust, fog, smoke, a robot that
does not rely on seeing is suddenly super
useful.
However, when we have good seeing conditions,
as you see, we have to be able to do better
than this.
So, can we?
Well, have a look at this new technique.
Well, now we’re talking!
This new robot is exteroceptive, which means
that it has cameras, it can see, but it also
has proprioceptive sensors too, these are
the ones that tell the orientation and similar
information.
But, this new one fuses together proprioception
and exteroception.
What does that mean?
The best of both worlds!
Here you see how it sees the world.
Thus, it does not need to feel out the terrain
before the navigation, but, and here is the
key.
Now, hold on to your papers, because it can
even navigate reasonably well even if its
sensors get covered.
Look.
That is absolutely amazing.
And, with the covers removed, we can give
it another try, let’s see the difference…and,
oh yeah!
Back in the game baby!
So far, great news!
But, what are the limits of this machine?
Can it climb stairs?
Well, let’s have a look.
Yup.
Not a problem.
Not only that, but it can even go on a long
hike in Switzerland and reach the summit without
any issues.
And in general, it can navigate a variety
of really difficult terrains.
So, if it can do all that, now, let’s be
really tough on it, and put it to the real
test.
This is the testing footage before the grand
challenge.
Flying colors.
So, let’s see how it did in the grand challenge
itself.
Oh my.
You see, here, it has to navigate an underground
environment completely autonomously.
This really is the ultimate test.
No help is allowed, it has to figure out everything
by itself.
This test has uneven terrain with lots of
rubble, difficult seeing conditions, dust,
tunnels, caves, you name it.
An absolute nightmare scenario.
And, this is incredible.
During this challenge, it explored more than
a mile, and how many times has it fallen?
Well, what do you think?
Zero.
Yes.
Zero times.
Wow.
Absolutely amazing.
While we look at how well it can navigate
these super slippery and squishy terrains,
let’s ask the key question: what is all
this good for?
Well, chiefly, for exploring under explored
and dangerous areas.
This means tons of useful applications, for
instance, a variant of this this could help
save humans stuck under rubble, or perhaps
even explore other planets without putting
humans at risk.
And more.
And, what do you think?
What would you use this for?
Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!